اسمح لي ان ابقى بموضوع الهجره قليلا هناك
فيديو
اعتبره الاجانب مستفز جدا وهذا الفيديو
الذي ظهر فيه ما توصل فيني تحديدا يحاور
صبيا تونسيا مهاجرا لا اعرف انكم تذكر هذا
الفيديو ام لا لكن كيف تنظرون
للمهاجرين بشكل عام و خاصه اولئك القادمين
من شمال افريقيا حضرتك
نريد توضيح اكثر
الهجره
من الاعلام رغم انه واضح ولا يحتاج الى
براهين اليوم المهاجرون الذين ينطلقون من
شمال افريقيا باتجاه ايطاليا لا ياتون
اساسا من دول شمال افريقيا وانما من دول
اخرى في القاره الافريقيه ويدعوني اذكر
ايضا بمعطيه متغفل عنه وخاصه من قبل من
يحملنا مسؤوليه الوفيات في عرض البحر
فعندما كان فيني وزيرا للداخليه واوقف
بشكل كبير وصول المهاجرين غير الشرعيه عبر
المتوسط راينا ايضا تراجعا كبيرا للوفيات
في المتوسط وهذا ما تم اخفاله في جزء من
الاعلام لانه في الكثير من الاحيان هذه
الرحلات غير القانونيه التي
تعتبر رحلات امل تصبحون
وهذا لا يمكننا باي شكل من الاشكال السماح